Speaker 1: You can find the The David Pakman
Show subreddit at David Pakman dot com slash
Reddit, that's our editor.
There are now more than 33000 of our viewers
and listeners who are subscribed there for
free.
You can post your thoughts about any of the
stories we talk about, stories you want me
to talk about or anything else that's on your
mind.
A few interesting posts that I spotted this
morning, user Pumpkin Pie says when it comes
to messaging, the right has a lot more upside
from the Rittenhouse trial than the Left.
No matter the outcome, I know this probably
isn't a popular view on a left leaning subreddit.
Just hear me out.
I don't think it's smart for the left to put
all their chips on the Rittenhouse case.
Agreed.
If Rittenhouse is found innocent, well, remember
it would be not guilty.
The right gets to take a victory lap.
Meanwhile, the left is stuck with complaining
about how unfair the world is.
I'm already cringing at the meltdowns.
We're going to see if Rittenhouse is found
guilty.
The right gets a new martyr going into the
midterms.
The left has to admit the system worked, which
undermines their argument about how broken
the justice system is and ultimately seems
self contradicting.
What are your thoughts?
I agree 100 percent.
I've been talking about this for a long time.
Either way, either way, the right wins on
the Rittenhouse trial, they will either make
him a hero or they will make him a martyr.
And the hero lion is Asian has already started.
I played for you the interview that Wendy
Rittenhouse, Kyle Rittenhouse, his mom did
with Sean Hannity on Fox News late last week
and it was all about Kyle is the victim, and
he's so great and the media is bad and the
prosecutors are bad and Democrats are bad.
Everybody's just bad, bad, bad and unfair.
And if we're going to come to a fork in the
road with the verdict, which could be hours
away could be days away, we don't know.
The jury is deliberating as we are filming
today.
If it if it's all not guilty, it is considered
a vindication of what Kyle Rittenhouse did.
It will also embolden vigilantism.
The idea that you can bring a gun into a situation
that is as an optional situation, create a
situation in which you feel threatened for
your life.
Shoot people in self-defense.
In the case of Joseph Rosenbaum, four times,
not three, not once.
Even though the first shot was disabling by
everything we know and then be found not guilty,
so it will encourage vigilantism, it's going
to be that's going to be if it's all not guilty,
if it's all guilty, it will be a biased trial
that never should have been filed.
This kid's being made an example out of and
he's the victim, and whatever time he serves
in prison will be considered his penance as
the martyr that he will be made.
Now there's also a completely plausible situation
where you get a mix of things.
You get not guilty on the major charges as
written, but may be guilty of some lesser
included charges or maybe guilty on one of
the minor charges and not guilty on the major
charges.
And then it's just going to be a propaganda
war.
But needless to say, the Left has very little
to gain from either outcome.
Justice aside, whatever you believe, to be
justice aside and the right is going to be
using this kid as either a hero or a martyr
for the foreseeable future.
Very accurate statement.
Another post I want to highlight from Reflex
Point is what happened to the hatred mail
segment.
Those were hilarious with the voice actor.
Did haters stop sending David emails?
Someone posted that there were legal reasons
for why we stopped it.
There's no legal reasons why we stopped Patriot
Mail, but I've told the story before, and
I'll tell it again when we stop doing hatred
mail, it was sort of in the heat of the 2020
election.
I and we were receiving way more death threats
than ever.
We were receiving things in the mail that
were more concerning than ever.
And in speaking with my contacts at the FBI
and other law enforcement agencies and kind
of just go and our security consultant, quite
frankly and going over the totality of everything
they felt, listen, at least for now.
The hatred mail thing is generating a lot
of noise relative to the signal, and it's
going to make it harder to more seriously
take to discern the real threats that need
to be looked into.
And so it wasn't a legal recommendation.
It was really more of a security recommendation
and hatred mail guy completely understood.
And this was a time when, as I've mentioned
before, FBI has shown up at the houses of
people that have sent us threats to talk to
them and evaluate whether they presented a
bona fide, bona fide threats.
And so we made the decision because things
have so escalated and the number of threats
was so high that we want to do anything we
can not to encourage more potential noise
and allow us to discern the signal.
Will it ever come back?
Maybe, maybe we're going to look into that,
but we decided to cancel it out because of
the craziness of the 2020 election.
This also relates to as many of you know,
we have we have a second studio and a lot
of other things that are going on.
OK, so it's all related to that.
I think I will leave it there.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot
com slash Reddit.